you owe me a video well Satan
I mean Matthew I will lick another video
how's it going bro Smiley's favor
welcome to duck game my favorite duck
game Oh fabulous fabulous sorry I have
to do that every time I don't know why
let's change your outfit really quick
cuz I want to be really quack I mean I'm
gonna have to go with senpai - can i
quack when ya guy
how does it work again get up I think
you hit up no no you don't hit up you
don't hit up right but Fred easy handled
a bad guy of it when when okay that's
the Kawai button [ __ ] Todd's 1,000 years
later alright jump you jump oh my god
alright I got it
all right oh I love it now what do I did
with you
when went high high jump on them
of course off cops [ __ ] + sucker my
duck ass there it is oh god I'm running
out of time ran in ten oh come on
I failed you Matthew looks like I'm
gonna have to remove a few millions
subscribers boy please give me another
chance
just play the damn game alright alright
alright alright I ride on that okay
let's try that again Lord Matthew [ __ ]
there it s look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's almost like I was born to do this
I'm not a duck I swear to God I was not
born to do this
disclaimer suck on a duck ass all night
long girl all night long how many
[ __ ] ducks are there eight more and
if no problem ran a problem now probably
might so ever how many am I supposed to
get this is ridiculous ah what does this
mean for the duck race balls
let's try grindy whatever it is it is
Sam fight duck one one one
yes I love you too that's his signature
oh oh oh I want that so much
oh god we're running out of time all
right duckling
Wow can you say that what what do you
mean fayla with scam it's [ __ ] this
is for Matthew come on ah come on baby
come on - laughs relapse relapse relapse
free lap dance Adam come on my shows
[ __ ] in tennis you know what I'm
gonna change to change hat for that I
think for now on I'll be known as the
[ __ ] assist one hey babe in it we're
fabulous duck fear for win
wait oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god it's going ever help
oh my god
one day I'm gonna go pro but it may be
that today oh my god so good get dr.
another day oh my god oh my god senpai
did I do it
yes that's right
you slept with my wife my wife ooh she
can only be mine
I gotta forget I run out of ammo we're
gotta kill him with my looks when mr.
duck is stuck working yet another late
night at the office on top of that it's
too stuffy to work better open some
windows am I just supposed to break
windows I might as well kill myself
ah how does a dumb [ __ ] can't talk I
wish I was a window see I have all that
that's it loose this is what all the
Ducks knew when they they're late for
work just break all the windows no one
will know a thing it all makes sense
really [ __ ] [ __ ] love at our office
that makes sense
alrighty then Brad I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did go ahead and leave
a latch or do this dance that I'm doing
right now go ahead try it out when it's
easy where anyone can do it when I press
thank you for watching we're all right
we'll continue in stay awesome brother
ramiz again my brother Harold over on
the benefit indeed side and now the
widow will be proud as they came in
taking
the kingdom indeed